hello everyone and welcome to a most
impressive game that was played
yesterday as part of Carson's banter
blitz session on chess calm his opponent
is Brazilian Grandmaster Luis Paulo
supey and it's quite the game as the
title suggests and also features the
Scandinavian defense which makes it even
better so let's just dive straight into
it a super width the white piece opens
with E 4 and the Magnus goes for his
Scandinavian defense with the D 5 we
have ecad presently 5 Queen captures and
the knight to f3 so not immediately
giving up kicking away the Queen with
Knight to c3 which is what most people
do but first Knight to f3 so maybe
you're gonna kick it away maybe not
maybe we're gonna play d4 c4i we'll see
what happens so Magnus takes this
opportunity to go Bishop to g4
immediately pinning the knight
threatening Bishop captures which were
the ruin of course White's pawn
structure and Bishop to e2 not allowing
that so now official captures this
Bishop can just recapture nice the c6
this is blacks usual plan of development
you wanna go Bishop g4 knight c6 you
want to play e5 you wanna Castle
queenside and if the Queen is under
attack you wanna bring the Queen back to
d6 however here after Knight to c3 the
bishops it has already been developed so
it's a bit of a different move order
than when you immediately attack the
Queen and usually the Queen will go to
d6 but now as the bishop has already
been developed just Queen to d7 so h3
challenging the bishop and here Magnus
straights characters captures and now
Magnus castles Queen side soupy castles
King side and now we have castles of
opposite sides much like in the game of
xqc versus nakamura so the plan is
simple white will attack here and black
will of course try and do some damage on
the on the King side and here the
position has already been reached in a
most notable game in 2009 Alexander
morosely which had it against Vladimir
Kramnik chronic played e5 here and he
was able to win that game but Magnus
goes for the immediate 90 d4 he
challenges the bishop here and it does
make sense it's a very strong leadership
so he wants to gobble it up and it is of
course as I move it that we have a
completely new game so supey starts his
expansion on the Queen side a for that
night the b5 is the idea
which is which is a very often played as
in this line of the Scandinavian black
ball more often than not Castle
queenside so even if black plays a six
there are some games were night can be
played to be five sacrificed a night to
open up the file for the rook I think we
covered one such game it was also a
blizzard game between our days of
fallujah in the Magnus where all it is
went for this sacrifice and the Magnus
didn't accept it in the end Magnus won
and okay King Tubby ate a nice
prophylactic move and now Knight the b5
so the night is now nicely placed there
and the thing is if you go for it if you
try and grab the pawn captures captures
and captures then you open up the a file
for the rook rook III fall by rook to b3
will be an idea and it will already be
very uncomfortable for black and this is
a blitz game you do not want to be under
attack
so Magnus instead eliminates the strong
light square bishop with Czech we have
Queen captures and now a6 pushing the
knight back but now a soupy of course
does not move the knight it's pretty
much the same as if a six was already
here and then you play that try to
sacrifice it so here he doesn't move if
he just goes c4 and even though even
though the engines are like a capture
Sun b5 as a human you you you usually
don't go for this
so Magnus instead continues developing
e5 now the bishop can be developed and
d4 now are challenging this pawn but
also freeing up a DF for square for the
bishop if Magnus decides to capture
which he does he grabs the pawn he
capped for Sundy for and now Bishop to
f4 putting pressure on the pawn here and
Bishop to d6 isn't really all that great
because you really ruin your pawn
structure in front of your king so
instead Magnus now decides to capture a
cap for Sun d5 with a cap for some b5
now you opened up the file for the rook
and now Magnus goes Bishop to d6 which
isn't all that great for black but for a
blitz game it's it's very hard to find
the absolute most precise move but here
there actually exists a c5 in the
position it's just very strong because
well whatever you do b6 is coming and B
six is very strong whether you capture
here or you capture here v6 is still
coming and it's just just a very strong
idea for example the shop characters
Queen a3 and there is no and there is no
stopping this you cannot make room for
the king the the pawn is pinned so it's
just game over
however soup we went for rook to a - his
idea is he wants to play rook after a
one and then deliver checkmate on a8 and
okay Magnus goes Queen to 5 which is
which is a good move as it attacks the
bishop twice now and also creates a
breathing room for the King so you can
run away to the Kings side if needed so
look after a one threatening rook to a a
to checkmate and now of course if you
capture you just get checkmated so
Magnus need to move the King he goes
King to c8 but even though it looks like
now our black defended he skincare
escape you can just capture the the
bishop here feel free to pause the video
and try to find the absolute winning
move for for supey while I give you a
couple of seconds and have the title of
the video in mind while while you're
looking for it so for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations on
spotting that the Kings escape route
involves the d7 square so for those of
you who just wanna enjoy the show its
Queen to c6 a most beautiful Queen
sacrifice you use the Queen and not
allow the King to reach the d7 square
and it was actually in this position and
move 18 that Magnus Carlsen resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here most obvious choice of course is
what happens if you capture the Queen
not much the pawn still prevents the
King from escaping and also guards b7 so
next move whatever you play rook to e8
is checkmate there's there there's no
move that even prolongs the game like
there are of course silly moves like
maybe Queen b1 check but other than that
rocked a a2 is completely winning on the
next move and if you don't play after
Queen to c6 if you don't capture the
Queen there's no other move you can play
like any move you play you just lose
there's no way to jump over the rook
even if there was the Queen guards e8 so
even that is impossible but yeah a lot
of you were saying that in the previous
video Nakamura
versus xqc that of course it lasted for
only 16 moves but here it only lasted
for 18 moves so as you can see it it can
happen to anyone and chest definitely is
a game for everyone so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it a lot of you
requested it so I thought why not today
after I saw that so I thought to myself
of course yes we are we are definitely
going to show this one it's a quite the
game I would like to think I would like
to thank Co a night of Center a Fred
Ackerman Salvador Albanese Dustin van
rehearsal and Dennis Myers for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and then it's
also sent me a very moving message and I
asked him if it was ok to share it with
you guys I thought it was just very
moving so here it is if you want you can
even pause the video to read it but I
could even read it he says hey I got
matter I recently got back into chess
after ten years of not playing my father
taught me and my sisters how to play
chess from a young age over the years he
got very sick and was confined to lying
in bed but he never stopped watching
chess and following the latest matches
last year he passed away now that I'm
getting back in chess I recognize your
YouTube videos as the thing my dad was
always watching this donation is for
your great content and thanks for
helping my dad stay entertained with the
game he loved so there you have it
like I said I thought it was just a very
moving message so I thought I'd share it
with you guys and I'm sure I'm very glad
that dennis is also gay Dustin is also
getting back in the chest and I'm sure
that his dad would would have enjoyed
that very much so once again I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the alan
doris a be checking up on you wonderful
suggestions such as this one and as
usual whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day